[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN SEALES: "Bandstand," the
new musical that explodes with
the most high-octane,
heart-stopping,
and best dancing onstage today--
which just won the Tony for
best choreography, by the way--
[APPLAUSE]
The show-- yes-- the
show is set in 1945
as America's soldiers come
home to ticker-tape parades
and overjoyed families.
Private First Class
Donny Novitski,
singer and songwriter,
returns to rebuild his life
with only the shirt on his
back and a dream in his heart.
So we're going to get a
commercial rolling for you guys
to get it started, and then go
straight into the performance.
[SWING MUSIC PLAYING]
ANNOUNCER: Direct
off "Hamilton,"
Broadway's hottest
director-choreographer creates
the best dance on Broadway in
the Tony-nominated musical,
"Bandstand," a dazzling,
stand-up-and-cheer new musical
but should not be missed.
"Bandstand," on Broadway.
[APPLAUSE]
COREY COTT: Hey, guys.
Hey, I'm Corey Cott,
play Donny Novitski.
Just so you know, we're all--
our cast is currently
questioning our life choices
by being in Google.
This is so cool for us, and are
super jealous of all of you.
So yes, so the show takes
place right after World War II.
My character comes back,
is very down on his luck,
struggling to find work.
My character, Donny, is a piano
prodigy-singer-songwriter,
dreams of being the next
Bruno Mars of the early '40s.
[LAUGHTER]
But it's really hard
because I've gone to war
and gone through
a lot of trauma.
And I'm trying to figure out how
to get my life back on track.
So I hear about a national
songwriting competition,
a swing songwriting
competition, that the winner
will get to be in an MGM musical
with their song featured.
And I get this idea
of assembling a swing
band with a bunch of vets.
And so this is the
song "Donny Novitski."
[MUSIC - COREY COTT, "DONNY
NOVITSKI"]
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks, guys.
And now I'd love to bring up my
lovely co-leading lady, Laura
Osnes.
Please give a round
for Laura Osnes.
[APPLAUSE]
LAURA OSNES: So I play
Julia Trojan in "Bandstand."
And my character is a war widow.
I lost my husband in
battle in World War II.
And it just so happens that
he, Michael, was best friends
with Donny Novitski overseas.
And so Donny comes
back and is feeling
this responsibility
and this charge
to check in on his buddy's wife.
And he finds out that I
sing in my church choir
and ropes me into being the
singer of this band of vets
that he's putting together.
So I reluctantly join this band
and realize that it is actually
going to be a beautiful healing
thing for my character, as well
as everybody else's
characters as well.
I write poetry as an outlet.
And Donny is inspired
by that and starts
setting my poems to music.
And we end up singing
one of the songs
that they write together
for the competition,
the statewide competition.
And so this is the
song that they sing.
And it's all about Julia's
desire and yearning
and wondering if love
will ever find her again.
[MUSIC - LAURA OSNES, "LOVE WILL
COME AND FIND ME AGAIN"]
[APPLAUSE]
LAURA OSNES: Thank you.
Thanks so much.
[APPLAUSE]
I'd love to bring Corey
back on the stage.
COREY COTT: One more
thing, actually,
just a little
tidbit-- we actually
all play our own
instruments in the show.
It's about a swing band.
And on that track that Laura
so gloriously just sang,
we're actually all playing
the instruments on that.
So I thought that
was pretty cool.
LAURA OSNES: That's true, Corey
plays the piano in the band.
And he practiced three hours
a day for the last nine months
and rocks it on
stage every night.
And yeah, we have trombone,
saxophone, drummer, trumpet--
what else?
COREY COTT: Bass.
LAURA OSNES: And bass!
And bass.
COREY COTT: Yeah, yeah.
LAURA OSNES: So you'll get to
meet those guys in a little bit
here.
We're going to do a talkback.
But this next song
is a duet that we get
to sing together in act two.
And as you can
probably tell, it's
a very complicated relationship
that these two have.
The closer they work together
and the more the music
helps heal them and
bond them together,
they start to have
feelings for each other.
But it's complicated because he
was my husband's best friend.
And there's other
difficult things,
if you come see the show, to
know the past that they have.
But they're also
the only two people
that knew her husband so well,
so they bond over that as well.
So it's tricky.
It's complicated.
And this next song--
yeah.
COREY COTT: Yeah, there's a
moment in the second act where
we get a little too
close and question
the feelings that we're
starting to have for each other.
[MUSIC - COREY COTT AND LAURA
OSNES, "THIS IS LIFE"]
[APPLAUSE]
COREY COTT: Thank you.
LAURA OSNES: Thank you.
COREY COTT: Thanks.
ALAN SEALES: Keep it going.
All right, the rest of the
cast, let's bring y'all up.
So we are now being joined
on stage, additionally--
I'll take my seat as well--
we've got Laura
Osnes, Corey Cott.
We're also being joined by Geoff
Packard, Joe Carroll, Brandon
Ellis, Patrick Connaghan,
and Andrew Leggieri,
and co-writers Robert Taylor
and Richard Oberacker.
Did I say that correct?
RICHARD OBERACKER: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: All right, cool.
Take a seat.
Get your water.
I always enjoy when
the people on stage
match the people
in the pictures.
That's very--
that's a lot of fun.
I want to touch on something
that, Corey, you and Laura just
said in the setup
of that third song,
that you played piano for three
hours a day for months, right?
COREY COTT: Yeah, mhm.
ALAN SEALES: So what came
first for all of you?
Was it learning the
instruments for the show,
or did the show come
and dictate that you
had to learn instruments?
COREY COTT: That's
a good question.
ALAN SEALES: Or for your
life, not the show, yeah.
You want to start down there?
GEOFF PACKARD: Yeah.
I'm Geoff Packard.
I play Wayne Wright in the show,
who is a marine coming back
from the war.
But he also plays the trombone.
I am an actor
first and foremost,
but I was in the high
school marching band--
[LAUGHTER]
--as a euphonium player.
Any low-brass, kick-ass
fans out there?
[LAUGHTER]
GEOFF PACKARD: No?
JOE CARROLL: Lots of then.
GEOFF PACKARD: But I went to
school for musical theater,
and they beat it into our
heads that you put everything
that you can possibly
do on your resume.
So I put that I--
and I played the trombone
in jazz band in high school,
so it was my second instrument
in high school, 14 years ago.
So I kept it on my resume.
And I picked it back up when
I did a reading of the show.
And they said, we're going
to do a lab now, so just play
the trombone for us and
we should be good to go.
And I went, oh, god.
[LAUGHTER]
So it was like
teaching myself again
how to speak a language
I barely knew, basically.
Does that answer the question?
I don't even remember
what the question is.
I just love this mic in
being here at Google.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: No, dude.
Yeah, so you already knew
how to play before you
joined the show, yes?
GEOFF PACKARD: Basically,
I knew nothing.
I played in high
school, but anybody
who plays a brass
instrument knows that if you
let your embouchure go
or your face muscles
that you use to blow it--
it's very tough to
pick that up again.
So I had to reteach myself
over a period of two years
to get ready to play with
actual musicians in the show.
JOE CARROLL: I have a
dead mic or something.
BRANDON ELLIS: Check.
JOE CARROLL: Can
I borrow your mic?
I'm Joe Carroll.
I play Johnny Simpson, the
drummer in "Bandstand."
And I was a crappy
rock and roll drummer
before I started this show--
and 1, 2, 3, 4, 1, 2, 3, 4.
And I've basically grabbed
hold of the pit drummer,
the guy who plays
in the pit, and
some other professional
drummers in town
and tried to get as
many lessons as I could.
But I played drums from a
very young age, and poorly.
And then, sort of
similarly to Geoff,
picked it up more
seriously when we
did a reading of "Bandstand"
about three or two
and a half years ago.
But I went to school for
musical theater as well.
And so I'm an actor first.
But from crappy rock and roll
drumming to intense swing
drumming, I feel like I'm
figuring it out slowly.
BRANDON ELLIS: My
name is Brandon Ellis.
I play Davy Zlatic the
attractive, young ingenue
in the show.
[LAUGHTER]
And I'm an actor,
first and foremost.
I started on cello, played
that most of my life.
Picked up bass around when
I was exiting high school,
played that for a while.
And really started taking
it seriously, though,
once we started doing this show.
In fact, much like
your chops, you've
got to build up calluses to be
able to play an upright bass.
And during our first
final callback,
my fingers cracked open
and bled everywhere.
But I didn't stop.
[LAUGHTER]
Booked it.
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
GEOFF PACKARD: So we came in
the first day of rehearsal
and we all had bloody
finger-- we cut our fingers,
we thought that
was the way to go.
LAURA OSNES: I'm lucky
because I get to sing.
I get to be the singer.
And yes, I've been
singing my whole life.
I dabble in piano, and I learned
eight chords on the ukulele
that I play in the show.
But these guys have
really worked hard.
COREY COTT: Yeah,
so I didn't know--
I knew a little
bit on the piano,
but I pretty much had
to learn everything
in the show and practice a lot.
ALAN SEALES: Really?
COREY COTT: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: I thought you'd
been playing your whole life.
I mean, everybody
else is amazing.
But you're featured so much,
and I was watching your fingers,
and you're going nuts.
BRANDON ELLIS: He's crushing it.
COREY COTT: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, it took a lot of sitting at
the piano when I was unemployed
for a long time and just
annoyed my wife every day
by playing the same songs over
and over and over and over
again.
So yeah, when you're unemployed
for a year and a half
and you have time to just
sit down and play every day,
it's pretty cool.
You can learn cool
stick skills and stuff.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: You say
you were unemployed
for a year and a half.
So were you trying to
learn piano to get this?
COREY COTT: To be fair, I
took some lessons as a kid
for four or five years.
So I knew very basic--
I've always sang, so I
could read music and stuff.
But I did not know how to--
I could barely do
a C major scale.
Yeah, I could not
do what I do now.
It took a lot of time.
PATRICK CONNAGHAN:
The two of you guys--
ALAN SEALES: So both
of you are swings?
PATRICK CONNAGHAN:
Yeah, correct, yeah.
ANDREW LEGGIERI: Correct.
PATRICK CONNAGHAN: So
we are understudies,
and we also swing, which means
we cover ensemble tracks.
But we both stand by for
two of the guys in the band.
So I've been a trumpet player
for close to 20 years now.
So I was always trying to book
the understudy role, which I
did, but on my final callback.
It took nine callbacks over a
year and a half to get here.
COREY COTT: Geez.
PATRICK CONNAGHAN: I'd been
playing trumpet the entire time
to the point where
I had all the music
memorized when I came
in for the callbacks.
And on my final audition,
I had my hand on the door,
and they were like,
what are your skills
like on the trombone?
And I was like, I don't
play the trombone,
but I'm confident in my ability,
and I'm willing to learn.
I think I could
learn the trombone.
And they were like, good answer.
[LAUGHTER]
So I got an email
with the offer.
And I'm scrolling
through, and so I
have Nick, the trumpet player.
I'm like, great, cool,
exactly what I wanted.
And then I keep going, and you
got Wayne the trombone player,
too.
And I was like, well, I guess
I need to go buy a trombone.
[LAUGHTER]
So I quit my job.
And I had a month of
unemployment where I just
locked myself in my apartment,
and I learned the trombone
from scratch.
So I used the foundation that
I had with brass instruments
and just transferred
it to low brass.
But yeah, I've also went to
school for musical theater,
so I've been singing for
a very long time as well.
So it's kind of an amalgamation
of all of the weird things
that I like to do.
So it's a dream job.
It's great.
Andrew.
ANDREW LEGGIERI:
I'm Andrew Leggieri.
I'm also a swing.
And a similar story to them--
I was an
instrumentalist younger,
and learned the alto
saxophone, and went to college
for musical theater, and had
to pick it all back up again.
And when this came
up, I had never
touched a tenor saxophone.
I rented one for the audition.
And then after I
got the job, they
were like, oh, we're starting
to add some clarinet stuff.
I'm like, great, I've
never, never played that.
So I looked up YouTube videos
and taught myself how to play.
GEOFF PACKARD:
Sponsored by Google.
[LAUGHTER]
GEOFF PACKARD: I will
also-- can I add that--
so the two guys that
they understudied
are musicians first.
And they are the two musician
members of the Donny Nova Band.
ROBERT TAYLOR: We
call those ringers.
GEOFF PACKARD: Yeah, exactly.
[LAUGHTER]
And they were both
in the horn section.
So I show up on the first
day, and the guy to my right
was a trumpet
major at Juilliard,
and the guy to my left was a
composition major at Berkeley,
and I played in the crappy
jazz band in my high school.
[LAUGHTER]
But it's really worked out.
And they had not
been on stage-- one
of them had not
been on stage ever,
and the other had very
limited experience.
So they did a good job
casting a broad skill
set so that we were able
to lean on each other.
Some of them leaned on us in
the book scenes or the acting
portions of the
show, and I certainly
leaned on them whenever
we were playing musically.
So they did a good
job of mixing it
so we took care of each other.
LAURA OSNES: Good point.
It worked It worked
for the monkeys,
it could work for you guys, too.
[LAUGHTER]
GEOFF PACKARD: How dare you.
ALAN SEALES: Hey, they
had two good seasons.
Hopefully you will
have many more.
And also, Andrew's going
on for the role of Jimmy
for the first time tonight,
so break legs, break legs.
[APPLAUSE]
Robert Taylor, Richard
Oberbacker, the co-writers--
where did the two
of you guys come up
with the idea for this show?
How long has it
been in the works?
ROBERT TAYLOR: It's
about four years ago
we first put pen to paper.
And we had this idea that we
wanted to really pay tribute
to musicals from The Golden Age,
but come at them from a very
contemporary perspective, in
that all of the situations
that MGM musicals tend to gloss
over in a Hollywood fashion,
we would actually be honest,
the actual circumstances
of the characters.
RICHARD OBERACKER:
That was really--
it was almost like
a thesis project,
where you basically say--
you look at all these MGM
movie musicals and The Golden
Age of Hollywood, and they're
building blocks of what we know
and treasure today.
I mean, "Hamilton"
is built on all
this stuff in a lot of ways.
But it was basically like,
well, OK, if on the town,
the three sailors came back
to New York for a day off,
but they really were
sailors, they really
were coming off the
battlefield, they really
had been through three years
of arms being ripped off
and heads being blown
off and ships going out
from underneath
their feet, what's
the truth about what this
country really went through?
And then that led to this idea
of, what kind of a country
just glossed over so
much of this stuff
and turned it into the greatest
generation when we know,
those of us that have these
parents that lived through it,
they became alcoholics because
they're numb to their pain?
And it was just this
amazing dichotomy
between what we
think of and what
we hold onto as our mythology
from mid-20th century
and how we just look at
it as this shining, almost
Emerald City.
But those of us--
you close the door
behind it, and you
remember grandpa was a mess.
And why was grandpa a mess?
And so that's really
where the idea was born.
So the cliches and the tropes
in this story were intended.
They just were
intended to be looked
at from a very, very raw
and realistic point of view.
ALAN SEALES: And then, so
how did it make it from paper
into the Paper Mill
Playhouse-- right?--
is where you workshopped it?
ROBERT TAYLOR: Yes, we
had a number of readings
only six months after we
finished the first draft.
We finished the first draft
in about three months' time.
Six months later, we had our
first reading here in New York.
And many of these
people were involved
in the very first
reading, and then
a couple of subsequent readings,
and then a big lab workshop
at Lincoln Center, and
then Paper Mill Playhouse
a year later.
And from there, our producers
decided we were ready.
ALAN SEALES: Many of
them are here tonight.
They swarmed in for this thing.
I love it.
[LAUGHTER]
RICHARD OBERACKER: They
just wanted the food--
[LAUGHTER]
--which is awesome.
ALAN SEALES: [INAUDIBLE]
to truck pit.
They liked the dessert.
[LAUGHTER]
So for the cast here, being
as young as all of you are,
I assume none of you were
actually in World War II.
How did you prepare
for these roles?
Did you talk to veterans?
Did you get a feel for
what they went through?
COREY COTT: Yes.
So some of us are wearing these
six pins that you guys see.
It represents an organization
called Got Your 6,
which is this incredible
vets organization that really
attempts to re-fabricate
the stereotype of veterans
in our society and
how they're actually
doing incredible
things for our society.
They're not to be pitied
or looked down upon.
But they're actually making
our society and culture
more stable.
And so one of the
things they do is
they look at different pieces of
entertainment films, TV shows.
And we're actually the
very first stage show
to be accredited by Got Your 6
as an accurate representation
of a veteran's story.
So they came and saw our show.
And they actually consulted on
the script with our writers,
and gave us feedback,
and have been with us
and guiding us for almost our
entire Broadway-- certainly
our Broadway experience
even before Broadway, too.
And so we had a
two-hour sit-down
where we, as the cast,
the Donny Nova Band,
got to talk with them and just
ask them anything we wanted to,
and they just gave us--
there was about 10 vets or so
from all different branches,
and gave us their thoughts
and insight, and were very
honest and vulnerable with us
about their experiences in
combat and losing friends,
and how they deal with that.
And that by far-- that
took our entire experience
in show and script to
a whole other level.
But paired with
that, we've also done
our own individual research
by reading many memoirs
and watching endless
documentaries in everything
from "Band of Brothers" to
"Patton," everything out there.
I mean, there's so many
resources on World War II,
especially.
But veterans today have
been a huge resource for us.
LAURA OSNES: And
just last night, we
had a group of Gold Star women,
wives and sisters and mothers
who have lost men in battle.
It was just women
last night, right?
There weren't the guys then.
Formed this organization
called taps.org,
which stands for
Tragedy Assistance--
COREY COTT: Survive--
LAURA OSNES: What's the P?
Tragedy Assistant--
yeah, it says on there.
Tragedy Assistance--
COREY COTT: I've
got it right here.
Tragedy Assistance
Program for Survivors.
LAURA OSNES: Program for
Survivors, so family members
who have survived and had
family members that died
in having to do with the war.
And we had just an amazing
little reception with them
last night.
And it was incredible
to hear their stories.
And they were in
awe of the show.
And we were just talking
about how they made a point
to say how truthful it was.
They could relate so much to
so many of the characters,
and to my character, especially,
because she's a widow,
and just how they felt safe, and
that they could laugh with us
and cry with us.
And that was really
an incredible honor.
And I'm fueled to do
the show again tonight,
because we had, again,
one-on-one firsthand
interactions with people
who have gone through what
our characters
have gone through,
and that's the really
special thing about it.
GEOFF PACKARD: And
the interesting thing
about the research,
for me, was that you
get cast in a show where you
get to play a combat veteran who
just comes back from the war.
In particular, my
character has struggles
with obsessive
compulsive disorder
and is a germaphobe,
and really interesting
things you get to
take on as an actor.
So you focus on that.
And for the first part of my
experience with "Bandstand,"
I focused on what
those differences were.
Then we met with these
veterans, and they all
told us their story.
And it was an overwhelming
idea that they
wanted to be portrayed as human
and not victims or heroes,
that they really
wanted us to focus
on what the human
aspect of these people
were-- they were fathers and
sons and lovers and humorists.
And we found it--
with this interesting
thing with our show,
it takes place in 1945.
And we have this great
device of swing music
to really represent that.
So a lot of research,
also, with learning
how to play the instruments.
We also had to learn
what swing music
meant to that time period.
And it, in a lot of
ways, helped these people
get through these
horrible things,
but also let them release
all the fun stuff.
And let them act out,
a lot like hip hop
does now, or real rock and roll.
So there was just
as much research
done on how to be authentic
to the swing music, as well.
ALAN SEALES: One of the most--
go ahead.
BRANDON ELLIS: Well, I
was going to say something
that I think is important to
talk about the story, where
all of these, like you
said, they overwhelmingly
want to be portrayed
as human beings.
And while this subject
matter, it's heavy,
and these people are going
through some heavy stuff.
Humans, in general, are
always reaching for light.
And this story is about
redemption and joy.
And while it may--
this stuff is a heavy
material to be responsible
for, the show is very joyful.
It's very much, everyone
is like reaching for light,
reaching for joy
the entire show.
And yeah, we have moments
where things catch up with us,
but in general, we're
trying to stay ahead of it.
So although it may
sound heavy, it's
actually a very joyful show.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, that's what
I was going to lead into was,
Andy Blankenbuehler, the
director-choreographer--
choreographer for "Hamilton,"
"In the Heights," the "Cats"
revival that's on
right now-- he's
just an amazing choreographer.
Of course, he won
the Tony for it.
Congrats again.
One of the most touching
moments, I think,
was there's this part in--
I think it's an intro to a song.
I don't know if you're
actually singing at the time.
But everybody comes in,
the lights are down,
and everyone's got weight.
There's another body hanging
on them, literally, on stage.
And you use the singing,
you use the songs to--
RICHARD OBERACKER:
They're playing
their instruments, actually.
It's a counterpoint, yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, yeah.
RICHARD OBERACKER: Yeah,
it's a counterpoint
that leads into a
rehearsal sequence which
leads into a church service.
And Andy physicalized each line.
A counterpoint is
basically lines
that intersect and become
a piece of composition.
And so he physicalized
that on the stage,
but each body is
attached to other bodies.
And the visual
image is, you just
see the weight, the
psychological weight,
that each one of these
band members carries.
ROBERT TAYLOR: Of the
men men they left behind.
RICHARD OBERACKER: The men
they left behind, yeah.
You guys could speak
to that moment.
It's stunning.
It's part of why
he won the Tony.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, it's one of
the most beautiful parts that
sticks out in my mind.
GEOFF PACKARD: Well,
it was interesting.
It was created-- that
part, it was hit upon,
touched upon at Paper
Mill, but fully realized
for the Broadway production.
And we were already
deep in rehearsals
when we had this moment with
these veterans from Got Your 6.
And one of the
first men who spoke
talked about never really
recovering from the combat
that they went through.
But they definitely
remember a moment
where the weight that they
were carrying was lifted.
And we all went, wait,
that's what Andy was doing.
Not only, actually,
because they, I guess,
wore flak jackets,
a lot of them.
And so they had to deal with
the idea of being lighter,
actually.
But it's a huge part of the
show is weight being lifted.
Some of us find our weight--
we hold onto that for
longer periods of time
than other guys in the band.
But yeah, it's a big part
of "Bandstand" is weight.
BRANDON ELLIS: And one of the
interesting things that he does
through counterpoint-- not to
ruin anything when you come see
the show-- but they're
on us, and as we are--
we all have vices
that we've turned
to deal with what is happening
to us in terms of what we're
carrying back from conflict.
And as the show goes along, and
as we're seeking and finding
redemption, those vices
switch to the music,
which is another thing that
the show is really about
is the redemptive and
healing quality of music.
And a lot of veterans turn
to art for that reason.
And as the show-- for instance,
myself, the show starts,
my vice is alcohol.
That's what I'm using
to deal with the pain.
And by the end of the
show, it's the music
that I'm using to temporarily
give me some relief.
GEOFF PACKARD: I swear
I'll stop talking.
But if Andy was
here, he would say
that it's difficult in a
musical, in particular,
to tell a story about a
generation of men and women
who didn't talk about
what they went through.
So we're telling
a story about guys
who didn't talk about combat.
And Andy, geniusly,
uses movement
to tell that story
while we play.
I don't know how else we would
tell that story without--
ALAN SEALES: Well, I have a
video that I'm going to show,
so I can tell it that way.
[LAUGHTER]
So if any of you guys
have any questions,
there's two mics in the aisles.
Start lining up
during this thing,
and then we can cut to you
guys as soon as we're done.
How many of you have been
staring at Brandon's tattoo,
by the way?
Yeah?
How many hours did that take?
How much pain was that?
GEOFF PACKARD: It's fake.
LAURA OSNES: It's
fake for the show.
JOE CARROLL: It's totally fake.
BRANDON ELLIS: Dammit, Geoff.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: It's for the show.
All right, roll the
Tony video, please.
PRESENTER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PRESENTER: In the armed
forces, Got Your 6 means
I've got your back.
I'm proud to say that
the organization Got
Your 6, which works
to empower veterans,
has partnered with the
thrilling musical, "Bandstand"
to highlight the experiences and
talents of America's veterans.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
PRESENTER: As the daughter
of a World War II signalmen
and the mother of
an army major, I've
seen how the scars of
service can haunt, even
in the best of situations.
Too many of America's
veterans are struggling
to find a new mission in life.
Their stories need to be told.
"Bandstand" is set just
after World War II.
As a group of veterans cope
with returning to civilian life,
they form a band unlike
any the nation has ever
seen and discover
the power of music
to find their voice, their
purpose, and redemption.
I'm honored to say to our
veterans, on behalf of Joe,
myself, the company of
"Bandstand," and everybody
here tonight, we've Got Your 6.
[APPLAUSE]
Now, featuring the
heart-stopping, Tony-winning
choreography of
Andy Blankenbuehler,
please welcome the
company of "Bandstand."
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - "BANDSTAND" COMPANY,
"NOBODY"]
[APPLAUSE]
ALAN SEALES: I love it when
the people in the pictures
and on the TV are also on stage.
That's very cool.
I've always wondered about this,
for the Tony's, specifically--
I mean, that must been
phenomenal for you guys.
A couple of you--
Laura-- have been there a couple
of times, which is amazing.
What's the process
for the Tony's?
Do they actually bring set
pieces in, or do they recreate
them just for the Tony's?
LAURA OSNES: That set is
actually a projection,
believe it or not.
ALAN SEALES: What?
LAURA OSNES: The back
of it was a projection,
and we brought in, literally,
the step, the platform step
that we brought from our stage.
ALAN SEALES: So after
the final Sunday show,
Broadway just brings a bunch
of set pieces to Radio City.
COREY COTT: Most of it,
actually, is projection, yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Huh.
COREY COTT: There's very few--
I mean, we brought
our instruments.
And they replicated those steps
that we had, the platforms.
But besides that, most
of it actually is--
I mean, if you go back and
look at the performances
from this year, you'll notice
that a lot of it is projection.
ALAN SEALES: You just
ruined everything.
LAURA OSNES: I know.
[LAUGHTER]
But it's incredible.
They verbatim made a real
projection of our set--
every picture that's
on there, every detail.
I don't know.
They must take a photo of
it, and then they legit--
GEOFF PACKARD: They
know how it worked.
LAURA OSNES: Oh, yeah.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
LAURA OSNES: We're amazed
at that sort of thing.
You guys are like, yeah.
ALAN SEALES: You're the ones
who designed it, probably.
LAURA OSNES: Yeah, exactly.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: How
does projection work?
[LAUGHTER]
I get too--
LAURA OSNES: But we all
had a matinee that day.
So what happens
on Tony Sunday is
that you go to Radio City in
the morning in your costume.
You go to the theater and get
in costume, go to Radio City,
have dress rehearsal, go back
to the theater, do a matinee.
And then we hung
out at the theater,
and streamed the beginning of
the Tony's, and then got back
in costume, and got on
a bus to Radio City,
and got off the number before
ours, and hung out backstage,
and then go, do your
number, get back on the bus,
go back to the theater.
It's a crazy day.
GEOFF PACKARD: The
interesting thing
is that the majority of the
cast that you see perform
spent most of the
actual broadcast
on a bus on, like, 50th
Street waiting to go on.
So the stage manager comes
out to your boss and goes,
you're on.
And then you go
backstage, then you go on,
and you go back to the bus.
It's not a--
COREY COTT: It's crazy.
GEOFF PACKARD: You
do get to see--
I shook hands with
Stephen Colbert.
And--
COREY COTT: Backstage
is crazy at the Tony's.
JOE CARROLL: Geoff Packard
shook Stephen Colbert's hand
with his pants
around his ankles.
[LAUGHTER]
He was getting his microphone
off, and I was standing--
we were getting our
microphones off,
and Geoff literally
says to Stephen Colbert,
can I shake my
hand even though--
what did you say?
GEOFF PACKARD: No, I said,
well, my pants are down,
I guess this is a good
time to shake your hand.
[LAUGHTER]
JOE CARROLL: Colbert looked at
him like he had three heads.
[LAUGHTER]
GEOFF PACKARD: He shook my hand.
ALAN SEALES: He's probably
heard that a lot, though.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: I didn't mean
it like that, come one.
So going back to the
military association,
I mean, it's such
a strong theme,
of course, with the
show and everything.
Have you, other than I've
Got Your 6 organization,
has there been any
audience feedback?
Have people come up after
the show and hung around?
I mean, what have you-- what
stood out for all of you?
JOE CARROLL: There's a
ton of those stories.
But one-- I mean, you can
speak more specifically to it.
But one of the
coolest ones, there
was a guy in the front row who
we-- we got to curtain call,
and he stood up.
And he was by himself, and
he just started clapping,
and he started mouthing to
Corey, he's like, I'm a vet,
I'm a vet.
And I think that you
just took his hand
and brought him backstage.
And he was a Vietnam veteran.
And he was like,
the post-Vietnam era
was so anti-military.
And he said something
along the lines of,
this is the first time
I've felt truly free of--
truly proud of being a
veteran, that was what he said.
This is the first time I've felt
truly proud of being a veteran.
There's a bunch
of those stories.
Fleet Week was amazing.
When Fleet Week
was happening, we
had tons of vets
in all the time.
COREY COTT: Yeah.
And even people that
didn't specifically serve,
there's so many
stories of them either
being related to their
grandfathers, or their uncles,
or dads, or
brothers, or sisters,
or moms who have
served in some way.
And in a lot of
ways, I think there's
been an expectation
to come see our show
with this idea of swing music.
And "Bandstand," you
have a certain idea
of what this could be.
And then you come--
and a lot of people
have said they've
come and been taken
to an experience, an
emotional journey,
that they didn't expect, and
felt that not only did they
have a good time and felt like
they experienced a great story,
but that they felt
like they honored
their relatives, that they were
taken to a place that respected
them.
GEOFF PACKARD: We
also got to meet--
he wasn't a veteran,
but he was one
of the most interesting people
I've ever met in my life.
There's a 19-year-old guy
named-- what's his name, Rob?
LAURA OSNES: Rishi.
ROBERT TAYLOR: Rishi Sharma.
GEOFF PACKARD: Rishi Sharma.
And he was from California,
graduated high school,
and was obsessed
with this mission
to meet and record all of
the living American World War
II veterans that
are still present.
And he did the math.
There's something like
however many die every day.
So he mapped out that there's
four years until they all die.
ALAN SEALES: Wow.
GEOFF PACKARD: And so he's been,
for the past year and a half--
RICHARD OBERACKER:
He's been doing it
about two and a half years.
GEOFF PACKARD: He goes
throughout the country
and contacts these men--
combat veterans, in particular--
and sits down with them,
and talks and interviews
them for about--
ROBERT TAYLOR: And gets their
actual stories, their combat
stories, on camera.
It's really--
RICHARD OBERACKER: It's
like the Shoah Foundation
for the Holocaust that Spielberg
was heavily involved with.
And so he's archiving
all this stuff.
And he's really the only one
in the world who's doing it.
He's 19 years old.
GEOFF PACKARD: And
immediately after the show,
we're like, well,
are you going to make
a documentary about this?
And he's like, no, no, no,
I give it to the veterans.
It's not really about what
goes into the footage,
it's about these guys
getting it off their chest.
And so immediately,
Corey and I were like,
yeah, man, I was feeling good
about the story we were telling
until we meet this 19-year-old.
But that's the best
part about this show
is that there are a lot of--
hopefully, when they
come and see it,
somebody asks a family
member, wasn't uncle so-and-so
in the war?
What was his story?
And that happened to each of us.
On some level, we
go, yeah, tell me
about Uncle Morty's
time in the--
and all of a sudden, you
get these new stories,
or these old stories
come out anew.
Our director, Andy,
came backstage
after the Tony's and said--
was it his uncle
or his grandfather?
COREY COTT: Grandfather
was in the 4th Marines
and had fought in the
Pacific, at Iwo Jima, and all
these other places.
GEOFF PACKARD: That's
the most common thing
is that, I didn't know,
but so-and-so did this,
or I didn't know, but my
next-door neighbor was a Gold
Star member, whatever.
LAURA OSNES: Yeah, right.
ROBERT TAYLOR: And my dad
is a World War II vet.
And all of the dads of the
kids I grew up with were.
And there were so
many things about them
that I couldn't explain why they
were these incredible people
that had explosive tempers
and that were, very often,
in fights and self-medicating.
And it's been really--
it's opened up, for me,
just a window into what they
were going through, writing the
show and working on the show.
And that's what I've seen--
other people who haven't
served themselves.
But it's opened up such a window
of understanding into relatives
and family members that--
it's just amazing that they're
suddenly realizing, oh,
that's probably why this man
has been so distant all my life,
or that's probably
why just the slightest
thing can trigger a response
I would not have expected.
ALAN SEALES: Well, we're
running short of time.
We do have one more
performance from you guys
I hope that you can give.
But I want to take one question
over here before we're done.
AUDIENCE: So I know you guys
talked a lot about the research
that you're doing to
develop your characters,
so I guess my
question is in regards
to an understudy or a
swing, how much flexibility
do you guys have to
make your own choices
versus taking what the, I
guess, original actor has done?
LAURA OSNES: Great question.
ALAN SEALES: Great
question, yeah.
ANDREW LEGGIERI: Good que--
I'll figure that out tonight.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, it would be my
first time doing this part
with these guys.
And I've been with the
show for two years,
so this is going to be a
whole whirlwind of emotions
and a whole whirlwind of,
am I in the right spot?
Am I saying the right line?
What's my next prop?
What's my next costume change?
So yeah, it's going
to be a lot of--
I think tonight is going
to be a lot of, just,
what I've worked on and what--
LAURA OSNES: Hitting the notes.
ANDREW LEGGIERI: --and going
to be as close to the show
as they know it,
because otherwise,
for me, I don't know, my mind
will be in a million places.
So yeah, I think the
first time I went on
for one of the other tracks, it
was very much saying the words,
making sure I have a character.
And then as I kept doing it--
I did it four times so far--
I felt like I was
able to flesh it out.
I was living in it more.
And it's not that I was
making different choices
from the other actor, but
we're just different people.
So it felt like when I
was living in it more,
I was bringing something to
it that only I can bring,
where I'm only me.
I can't really
replicate anything.
But the more comfortable
I feel, then I
feel like I can live in it.
And it's probably going
to be different, for sure.
But yeah, I hope that
answered your question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that was good.
ALAN SEALES: You should get
it fake tattooed on your arm.
You can just look at
your arm the whole time
with the big wings
on it or something.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, cool.
Thank you all so
much for coming in.
Hopefully there's one
more song you can all
sing for us as a group, yes?
So everyone, go check them
out-- bandstandbroadway.com.
On Instagram and
Twitter, @bandstandbway.
If you're taking pictures
and want to share them,
the hashtag is
#strikeupthebandstand.
They're at the Bernard B.
Jacobs Theater, 242 West 45th.
Please help me give them
a round of applause,
and we'll get one
more song out of them.
[APPLAUSE]
RICHARD OBERACKER:
[INAUDIBLE] are
moving these chairs is this
last song is the end of act one.
And you've been hearing
about this radio contest
that they all enter.
It's states, and then nationals.
So at the end of
act one, they've
won the state competition.
They've believed all
along that NBC and MGM was
going to treat them like stars
and take them to New York
and their dreams were
going to come true.
And right before
the song happens,
they find out that, no, you
have to pay your own way.
And in fact, when you
get there, there's
another preliminary
off-air because the contest
is only two hours.
So in other words, they're
screwed and they can't go.
And so this song is
really about Donny
realizing this dream of riding
this first-class train that
got him through the war-- it's
what got him through the battle
is dreaming that he gets to take
this train, and go to New York,
and be a star, and play
on the greatest bandstand
that New York has to
offer is just smashed.
[MUSIC - "BANDSTAND" COMPANY,
"RIGHT THIS WAY"]
[APPLAUSE]
COREY COTT: Thank you, guys.
Thanks so much for having us.
LAURA OSNES: Thank
you guys so much.
COREY COTT: Come
see "Bandstand."
We'd love to have you.
And enjoy being--
LAURA OSNES: The rest
of your day at Google.
COREY COTT: --an awesome
employee at Google.
This is great.
[LAUGHTER]